all right the next section showing up
you know the first talks given by a
present sitting who's now at Harbor but
starting at Berkeley soon thank you so
much thanks to the organizers for
inviting me to talk so today I am going
to be talking about some recent work so
recent it's still in progress called
representation via representations
worked with Cynthia dork as well as our
collaborators at the Harvard School of
Public Health
Giovanni parmesan II and Prasad Patil
who are experts in biostatistics
particularly use of cancer and have
really provided a lot of inspiration for
the problem that we're addressing so I
want to give a quick outline for what
I'm gonna talk about today first I want
to motivate what is the question in
biomedical prediction that we're trying
to solve here second what are the
challenges in out of distribution
generalization that we face then I'm
gonna take a detour into adversarial
methods that have been developed in the
fairness literature and describe how
they can be applied to this problem how
we've incorporated them into our
representation via representations model
and then some preliminary results we
have and then conclude and provide some
future directions so what is biomedicine
up to today well over the past couple of
years there has been a lot of hope for
precision medicine and personalized
medicine including 20 the 2015 State of
the Union address by then President
Obama announced this huge initiative to
provide health care tailored to you to
move away from this model of medical
treatments designed for the average
patient but to really take into account
individual differences and allow for
medical treatment to be tailored to each
person and it's really big business as
well so the global cancer in tumor
profiling market is projected to reach
twelve point four billion dollars in the
next five years from already billions of
dollars right now so there's a ton of
hope what has come up with what has come
from it well there's a lot of worry
still so there's a worry about whether
these biomedical predictions which come
out of academic studies actually turn
into real results
in the clinic and real treatments for
real people so one thing that has been
pointed out is that cross study
validation indicates that conventional
methods of estimating how well you're
going to do on future populations
conventional cross-validation is
overestimating accuracy in case people
aren't familiar with these two ideas I'm
gonna go and describe both cross
validation and cross study validation
really quickly so cross validation is
this idea that if you want to figure out
which algorithm is gonna work well on
your problem you want to choose between
a logistic regression or random forest a
neural network you want to choose the
right hyper parameters for that model
you're going to want to test on some
held out data to make sure that you have
an overfit on your training data so you
might collect a data set and you might
hold out some of it or train on some and
then hold out others as tests but you
don't want to just be biased towards
this random 20% that you how about four
tests so maybe four cross-validation you
actually iterally
iteratively hold out a different segment
of your data set as the test and then
you average the form performance of your
classifier on all of these different
folds and then you figure out hey
logistic regression did the best and now
I'm going to retrain it on the entire
training data set and use that in the
future so cross study validation takes
this step I take this takes this one
step further by saying you get inflated
estimates if you just look at one data
set that's been collected at one time
from one Hospital what in fact is going
to tell you a better measure of
generalizability is if you collect many
different independent data sets so I'm
trying to indicate that with different
colors so different hospitals different
people collected at different times and
at this point you do a similar thing you
hold out different portions as the test
set and you calculate average
performance and now you want to see
which is my which is the algorithm that
does the best one of the hyper
parameters that I should use
unfortunately the ranking of the best
prediction algorithm often changes when
you compare cross study validation
versus conventional cross validation
simple predictors often do better than
complex ones so your linear regression
often does better than a neural network
meaning that although you thought that
you had properly defended against
overfitting you probably still are
overfitting and this is happening in the
real world so biologists have raised
alarm the biomarker discovery field is
replete with molecular signatures that
have not translated into the clinic and
this continues to be the case so this
was observed in 2014 but it's still
happening to this day and what are the
fairness implications of this well
biomedical studies tend to be conducted
in large research hospitals not rural
clinics and precision medicine will only
benefit these segments of society unless
we exclusively try to improve the
applicability of these predictors to
unrepresented populations and
unrepresented is really important
because there are some groups that are
not just underrepresented but really not
in any training data data set it at all
one example of this is the Havasupai
Indian population who for historical
reasons are not willing to participate
in future biomedical studies and will
not be present in any training dataset
but I would claim that it's a fairness
concern if they're not going to have
accurate predictions coming out of these
personalized medicine initiatives so why
don't predictors generalize I want to
walk through a couple of the reasons not
a comprehensive list but some of the
reasons that biologists have highlighted
to say these are the main these are some
causes for why generalization is hard so
one thing that happens are these
mysterious batch effects which are just
systematic differences between samples
that are processed and measured in
different batches and it's kind of a
vague term but it just means even if you
control everything you could think of
even if you grow a cell culture from the
same line have the same technician
handle them
grow them for the same amount of time in
the same lab but just a couple hours
apart you will often see batch effects
you often see slightly different gene
expression values when you then do some
kind of DNA assay on this later
aside from those kind of batch effects
also there are things that make a lot of
sense if you use different equipment if
you use a different companies assay you
will often get different results if
different technicians handle samples if
you have biological variation in the
underlying populations that creates
spurious correlations not really related
to your phenotype but it sort of messes
up your classifier or if you have also
phenotype associated biological
variations so things that are actually
related to your outcome of interest and
finally if you have really noisy
measurements so that your just a problem
in the community there's been a lot of
growing interest to address this problem
some proposed solutions include
explicitly trying to train a simple
classifier that's geared towards
reducing the possibility of overfitting
so one example of this is this mas o
menos method where you calculate a risk
score based on the sum of sort of bad
features features that seem correlated
with a bad outcome minus the sum of good
features and so instead of doing the
linear regressions it's almost like
everything just has a coefficient of
plus one or minus one
another example is training replicable
predictors in multiple studies where you
train an ensemble of predictors you
explicitly have access to multiple
studies and then you use a cross study
validation kind of ensemble entomb ake
sure that your waiting by the ability
for a particular predictor to generalize
and finally one more example is in
embedding independent validations
datasets within a study so explicitly
talking about validation to
out-of-sample rather than and collecting
this independent sample yourself and
holding it out okay so now I'm gonna
take a quick detour into talking about
some literature unfair representation
learning which was covered a little bit
by Richards MO yesterday and I'm gonna
tie this back later in the talk to see
how it addresses the outlined so far so
what is the goal of fair representation
learning we want to learn
representations that censor sensitive
information so the idea is maybe we want
to allow a system to use a classifier to
classify people but we're pretty afraid
of some malicious actors if they have
access to this sensitive information
maybe they can discriminate on the basis
of it and so what we want to do is learn
a mapping from data to representations
that stamps out sensitive information
but at the same time retains other
useful information for classification
and so we can handle this representation
to anyone and be sure that they're not
going to discriminate on the basis of
these specific sensitive features that
we have isolated that we've censored out
so this may not be the right fairness
notion for all situations in particular
there are a lot of cases where you might
want to be aware of sensitive attributes
rather than censoring them out but it is
entering real world use in a lot of
cases for example San Francisco using
NLP to automatically redact information
from police reports I could identify a
suspects race and that's some of shrug
dwells work with the Stanford
computational biology lab and about to
be rolled out
sorry policy I'm in the biology zone
right now so what one example of this
learning fair representations approach
is using adversarial learning so
adversarial neural networks in this
setting what we have is imagine you have
a data set X and it's made up of green
people and blue people and green people
and blue people also have a sort of
shade to their color and the shade is
what we're gonna say is relevant for
their classification but their color
green or blue is maybe the sensitive
attribute that we don't want to have
left in the representation so what we're
looking for is a way to map from X to
our representation Z through this
encoder some blackbox neural network
that is going to preserve the shading we
still have dark and light sections but
it no longer shows whether you're a
green person or a blue person original
how we train this is we have a multi
objective thing going on so we want this
representation Z to be relevant to our
outcome of interest Y whether that's
providing a loan to someone or you know
whether their tumors get on the hosta
size and so we are going to make sure
that there's a predictor that does well
predicting Y hat at the same time we
want to make sure that Z is no longer
showing the greater blueness so we have
an adversary who's trying to guess all
the time whether someone is green or
blue which is a hat attribute and then
finally we also have a decoder which is
trying to start from representation Z
and go back to X and ensure that the
representation Z is still holding on to
as much information about exes possible
much information is supposed to mean so
you just go on it'll be clear from the
loss function right so essentially you
want reconstruction to be possible and
you want to they devise a reconstruction
loss
okay so the loss function eventually
that you at a high level that you're
trying to optimize is some some hyper
parameter alpha times the loss for the
predictor may be zero one loss we're
mean squared error loss some beta term
times the loss of the decoder which is
like a reconstruction loss and then a
term for your adversary so that is a way
that you can trade off a couple trade
off these hyper parameters to see so
that was learning fair representations
what does that have to do with the
problem that I was introducing earlier
we have a hypothesis that for certain
biomechanical tasks there exist
predictive invariant features that are
invariant across populations and this
hypothesis comes from not just an error
but a lot of conversations with Giovanni
and Prasad and other people in the
biomedical space who really think that
this is a reasonable hypothesis to claim
about certain biomechanical tasks gnosis
predicting five-year survival rate
certain things like that bulking so
that's about whether surgery is a good
option to treat your cancer and so using
this hypothesis we conjecture that
techniques for censoring sensitive
information in the fair representations
literature can help us to learn
predictors that will be accurate on
unseen populations and how we're going
to do this is use data from multiple
institutions or multiple studies done at
different hospitals and use that to
censor out study specific features and
build a predictor based on these
invariant features so this is starting
to sound a little bit like domain
adaptation which some of you might be
aware of so I want to highlight some
differences with a lot of that
literature domain adaptation is about
using data from one source distribution
to transfer to a particular target
distribution so people are really
interested in this because a lot of
times we have
for example imagenet a huge data source
collected in the western world but we'd
like to still be able to do image
recognition on other places in the world
and so we want to use data from this
source distribution to still be accurate
later on a new target distribution the
common settings that we see domain apt
adaptation at work are to claim that
okay if we have abundant source data X
as well as labels for this source data
and a small amount of target data and
labels then we can transfer with this
set up or secondly we might have
abundant source data and their labels
and abundant or at least a significant
amount of target data X but no target
labels Y and what you're doing is hoping
that if you make your source data X look
like your target data X then the labels
will also transfer but in our setting we
don't require any training data X or
labels Y from the target population what
we're relying on is our hypothesis that
they really are in variant features and
an invariant function that goes from
features to the label I get that and
then I want to recommend to other people
and I don't know who these other people
are going to be
for them so a lot of transfer learning
tries to transfer still using knowledge
of the future distribution or making
assumptions you say it's familiar
I didn't tell me tell me the best place
to look for the current state of affairs
thank you very much I'm a little
confused about how the existence of
invariant features sits well with the
goals of precision medicine the idea is
that there's something particular about
each individual that that you're going
to use so the goals of precision
medicine often are saying that there are
specific gene biomarkers or specific
things which you know aren't necessarily
present in everyone but mean the same
thing for across different people so
that if you were to present with this
biomarker it might only be present in a
fraction of the population and that's
why it hasn't been studied at wide scale
now because it's an orphan condition it
only affects a small proportion of
people only a small proportion of people
have this biomarker but when it's
present it really indicates something
about disease
like on its face that seems like what
you'd really want to do is learn like a
causal model and this actually sounds
like it might do that have you thought
about yes right I think it would be
great to be get to be able to get at a
causal interpretation of this we don't
have any formal connection with it right
now but it's it's a question that we're
just a comment to that question so there
are some recent work for the invariant
causal prediction which essentially
works and releases our assumption that
we have some invariant features across
different populations and then there is
a community of people who try to reason
that they believe those are the most
predictors because it's kind of stable
across populations
right so quickly a return to what I was
talking about earlier about why
predictors don't generalize and weather
our method addresses these sort of
issues so we have batch facts still and
we censor out these batch effects we
have pot size that we can different
equipment
let's censor out equipment affects
different technicians head examples
let's sensor out these technician
effects non phenotype associated
biological variation in the underlying
populations we should be able to censor
these out now the the thing the the
story changes a little bit when we talk
about phenotype associated biological
variation and the story is a little
complicated because our hypothesis may
or may not apply if there's really
biological variation that we have no
data on and that's related to the
outcome it's possible we can't
generalize well to those and you really
need to validate a model on a new
population to assess facilities also if
you have noisy measurements you need to
get better data so what is
representation representation via
representations trying to do we have now
an X that's made up of many different
studies coming from hospitals for
example and we still want to do a
similar thing learn a mapping to a
representation Z that gets rid of that
study identity now is our sensitive
attribute but still retains the
information relevant to classification
and then we train it in a similar setup
with the predictor and a test time what
we do is we freeze the end coder and the
predictor now we have a new study study
k plus 1 a new color but we hope that
this is still going to work that it's
still going to map down to a useful
representation Z and that it's still
going to be an accurate prediction Y hat
and so the specific loss function that
we use for the adversary is here
tailored to a multi study setting where
you have normalized loss where the
adversary is trying to guess from the
representation what the true attribute
was going in reference to modders at all
and the original learning fair
representations work this can directly
connect to improve Li connect to ferrous
notions they can
and so a here is a one hunt and coding
of the study identity so for example
what that means is study one out of four
would have a equal to 1 0 0 0 and study
2 would have a equal to 0 1
so in our setup we're we're motivated by
this biomedical setting working with
real data in this setting though is
often difficult because of the very
small sample sizes and so are a lot of
the work from our collaborators has been
on synthetic or simulated data that
comes from realistic data and so we
followed a lot in that mold to start out
looking at synthetic data and so now I'm
going to describe how we generated that
synthetic data and why is that it makes
sense in a biological context
so let's imagine we are now going to
look at sort of one row out of our
entire data set so this is one hospitals
input or one input from one Hospital
blue is going to be study I so and we're
gonna assume that the X features can
bleep it up can be split up into
invariant features and study specific
features and that there's an F invariant
that applies to the X invariant and a
series of different F Prime's that apply
to the study specific features K
different ones for all the K different
hospitals to restrict attention to our
blue Hospital let's look at just F prime
I so probably generate the data is we
choose a base rate for study I we draw
wide according to a Bernoulli and we
have a different base rate for every
study so that's one source of
heterogeneity then we draw X from this
normal distribution also different for
each study and draw an epsilon noise
term from a standard logistic
distribution and what we do is some
rejection sampling so we only retain
this X Y pair if Y if the Y that we've
drawn is equal to sort of the outcome of
both of the studies specific and the
invariant function where the study
specific is just left alone but we have
this noise term that we add to the
invariant function so we make the signal
a little weaker in the invariant
function and this way we're trying to
make sure that our whole setup is
actually learning the invariant function
even when it's almost incentivized to
learn the study specific functions
what's the mapping on that right great
question that's the next slide so what
are these F's the ones relevant for
genomic analysis seem to be largely
based on linear functions with some few
interaction terms or complications added
on top so most biologists think that a
lot of right a lot of phenotypes can be
explained by largely linear effects so
what we looked at is a completely linear
F we also looked at linear with a few
pairwise interaction terms including
product interaction terms so gene one
times Jim two and logic interactions so
are both gene one and gene two above a
certain threshold and also composites of
two linear functions so if we take half
of the invariant function half of the
invariant features apply function to
them apply another function to the other
half and then compose them with the
threshold do you mean like they're
pretty expressed by that she's yes
expression value yes
so always the signal from the study
specific features is stronger than from
the invariant features they're trying to
really stress test our model so what are
some results starting out with
completely linear functions this graph
is trying to show a 3d plot where we
change the fairness coefficients so if
you remember the loss function from
earlier this is the coefficient that
affects how much the adversary is trying
to tamp out the study identity and then
the reconstruction coefficient is for
the decoder to try to make sure that the
representation Z is still is able to
reconstruct X well as in this 3d plot we
have the representation field
representations model here we see that
at fairness 0 when it's just a free
neural network it seems to overfit it
does pretty poorly on this totally held
out test set but as you increase the
fairness coefficient as you force it to
censor out the study identity you see
that it's performance increases it gets
better it's error decreases and for
baselines we have a random forest and a
logistic regression
these were trained on just the merge
data sets but we also have baselines
where they're trained using a multi
study ensemble a method that's trying to
really explicitly take into account that
they come from multiple studies and they
do pretty much the same so to not
clutter this graph I didn't include
lines so it seems to be here it's hard
to see this PT graph but it seems to me
here that you just want to crank up the
fairness coefficients as high as you can
I mean
performances of digne that corner
proposes to us just yeah I think it's
hard to see it actually does start to go
up at the end so there seems to be a
sweet spot for the fairness coefficient
if you crank it up to high performance
degrades as well and I'll show some more
graphs and in this case when it's a
completely linear function we see the
logistic regression almost has an
inherent advantage because it's the
model that the data is really being
generated from moving on to slightly
more complicated terms we have a linear
function with an interaction term in
this case we actually see that the
representation of your representations
approach always does better than our
baselines so maybe just the neural
network is already great when we look at
a cross-section so I took one
reconstruction coefficient value and
just looked at as you vary faris we see
that you start out doing pretty well but
you do even better by increasing your
fairness so efficient so a similar
qualitative results and we see that
interaction terms are important for
getting rid of the advantage of logistic
regression
now one other example of a data step
that we looked at is if we take two
linear functions and take the logical or
of them and I think this one shows the
nicest curve of accuracy of error
decreasing as you increase fairness
coefficient but then not changing very
much pretty well without having to crank
it up to sorry you mean I don't have
like a color graph so the baseline
models don't have any hyper parameters
that I tuned to show in this graph so I
just plot them at like a single
so so the so the coloring is just to
help you see this surface a little more
clearly and there's no coloring for this
one because it's just okay so a
complication though is that when we add
many more studies so all the previous
graphs that I showed were dealing with
for training studies and then one
totally held out test study and when you
have many more studies added to the
training this was with ten studies in
training 111 study held out for test
what you start to see is that the random
forest actually does pretty well and our
VR it doesn't do terribly but it's not
that great it's significantly worse than
our VR or then the random forest and
what we think is going on here is that
the random forest has been pretty
limited in its scope and it can't over
fit to all ten different training
studies and so it starts to be forced to
rely on the invariant features as well
so are there scenarios where setting the
reconstruction coefficient says large
actually increases
because in innocence he knew what the
task was up front of it I don't care
about reconstruction I just care about
being given by the records right so in
the linear case the actual best point
for our VR is for nonzero reconstruction
but we do see it in some cases and
that's a really interesting question as
to why are you stretching helps flow
we're not transferring to a different
task we're actually trying to do the
same job
so so we think the random forest has
somewhat of a benefit when you add many
many many studies to your train set and
also we think that there are some
difficulties with the adversary training
when you have this many studies because
of our data generation set up all our
X's come from Gaussian distributions
with slightly different means but we
think after you add a certain number of
them it gets hard to really pin down
exactly which Gaussian it came from the
adversary has a difficult time and
adversary is no longer forcing the
encoder to do a good job of censoring so
another example of that study so these
are both cases where RvR seemed to do
better than both baselines without very
much hyper parameter tuning and then now
in the 10 studied case we have a lot so
to conclude main takeaways are there are
many different reasons a model might
fail in a new context some of these
reasons are due to a failure to find the
right invariant features and adversarial
methods developed in the Ferriss
literature to learn fair representations
can actually help learn these invariant
features however I still think I would
argue that models should be validated in
new settings if possible the
representation be a representation
method though can create a better
starting point can make sure that your
overfitting on as little data set
specific noise
and finally I think there are a couple
extensions of this potential work so
still in the biology space you could
imagine that x-ray images taken at
different hospitals or taking on
different equipment might show a similar
structure of variation the Shepards
project to try to transfer image
recognition and face recognition across
different contexts and any other sitting
settings were really you expect
invariant features and as others have
mentioned in comments and questions I
think a causal interpretation it would
be really great the first that was
really interesting I don't know much
about the domain but like I would guess
like like in your example of urban
hospitals versus real hospitals that
there is a lot so demographic
differences like the age distribution
and rural hospitals are they different
I'm a race like I mean also guess that
these things are at least age is sort of
relevant to some of both precision
medicine application it's like you might
worry that like if this is a
regularization you're proposing is to
stop anyone from being able to like
guess better than you know I got a
randomly which studied some point comes
from they can get like some advantage
just by you know guessing that the study
that you came from was the one in which
you
sort of demographic populations most
frequent and then stopping that kind of
advantage seems like it would endure you
from being able to target features like
that the part of the great so so the
last functions I showed were for that
kind of demographic parity idea where
you really don't want to do better than
a coin flip but the the last one should
we use more often in those experiments
are actually more akin to the equalized
odds framework so you want to make sure
that of the positive classifications
you can't tell between one group and
another
so hopefully that gets around some of
the issues this big one put for the
codification question in the comments so
you had this one thing in terms of the
other this study we mentioned all kinds
of things you'd want a sensor where do
these come in because it then and the
method of interest and correctly or just
basically you have a bunch of different
studies origin of the study was so is
that just a interpretive justice
motivation or is that actually goes into
the methodology right it's just
motivation and trying to sort of train
intuition about where this variation is
coming from and where which settings we
might actually hope so it's not that
when you use it you actually make this
list of your different technicians with
the consultant in this in the comment
it's related because of what should I
mention it I think one possible baseline
here would be think in terms of star
based multitask learning so multitask
learning
usually we use that to generalize that
multitasking when the cursor between
them another way to think about that if
you have if you think of each studies a
different task and if you're setting up
the problem is a starbase multicast or
any meaning
you know this started basically just
mooning you roughly a1 base predictor
and then playing and then one especially
predictor for each study where you want
to have the especially as predictor be
similar to the baseline predictor to be
somewhat similar to the basin predictor
if you try to fit especially splitter to
each study and then use the centralized
predictor in order to to generalize to
new studies that has that also has the
effect of removing the kind of study
specific stuff that will hopefully be
captured by the variation things
specialized predictors and the
centralized predictor and so I'm
wondering if that that might be a good
baseline also to compare to here in
might be relevant approach you know that
is kind of standard protocol you think
you have data that's coming from a bunch
of sources or have some commonalities
but also something doesn't use training
data from now so you don't so the way is
here you you have the training data from
think of each one of the studies is a
separate the test each one of the
studies and you're going to learn a
different particular for each one of the
studies where you're also going to
constrain all these different predictors
to be similar to some centralized
particular it also better learn so you
don't need training data from future
test you just have training data we can
that's thanks Francis
[Applause]